the consultation process has reached an
end and all the indications are that
next week the government will give the
go-ahead for a high-speed rail line
between London and Birmingham industry
Chiefs say it would create jobs boost
business and give the economy a
much-needed shot in the arm Britain has
practice make do and mend on the
railways for many years now we had the
extraordinarily disruptive upgrade of
the West Coast Main Line they cost nine
billion pounds we can't afford to go
through that again only to find it full
in a few years time when you take a
radical step to increase capacity and
the high-speed rail line a full national
high speed rail network is the answer
the country currently has just 70 miles
of high-speed rail track the proposed
new scheme would cut journey time from
the capital to Birmingham to just 49
minutes business leaders have long
argued that Britain's poor
infrastructure is a major obstacle to
long-term growth the proposed new
high-speed rail link would change that
but at what cost it's a very expensive
project and the figures that build up
the business case are pretty dubious but
the second one is the environmental
issue because the original report in to
hs2 said that there was no particular
environmental advantage you know it's
pretty much environmentally neutral now
if you're going to spend 17 billion
pounds for the first phase you'd expect
that they would be at least
environmental advantage so I think
that's the big weak point the scheme has
met fierce opposition from campaigners
who say swaths of English countryside
including the children Hills would be
cut in two by the new rail line the
entire cost of the project would be 32
billion pounds if it happens what won't
start for another four years with a
finish date of 20 26 and the Brady Sky
News